- We were, we cheated and
we were talking backstage.
- [Hilary] I know, I know.
- But I saved this,
this outfit is adorable.
I love this outfit, it's so cute.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
Yes, it's... You know what?
I'm excited to get dressed up.
- [Kelly] And it's been a minute,
since we've seen each other.
Oh yeah, do you not get?
Oh yeah, that's true.
Because of the pandemic, people
don't usually do that yet.
Oh, I've been doing it for a minute.
So, I'm excited still about PJs.
(Hilary laughs)
So, so it's good to see though,
but we're, we're coming
up on your third baby.
You have three babies.
- I do.
- It's a lot of work.
And it's her first birthday? Is it?
- Yes, in March, she's turning one.
I know.
I actually, my son turned,
is turning 10 in March.
I know double digits, I'm freaking out.
So that's Mae-Mae.
- Look at that ponytail.
- [Hilary] I know, we call her "Sticks".
Because like, her ponytail
just goes up in a stick.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Hilary] That's Luca.
- [Kelly] Oh, this is your 10 year old?
- [Hilary] Yes, and so,
their birthdays are the 20th of March
and the 25th of March.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, yeah, third baby,
you know, kind of thing.
So, on his birthday I was just like,
"Don't come out, don't come out".
- Oh yeah, you don't want
to have to share, yeah.
- No, I know, but now I'm always going to
have to plan like, two
birthday parties in March.
- Throw them together, yeah.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I can't, one's 10, one's one.
- I don't care.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- [Kelly] They'll be fine.
But you've had a a home birth
for your second baby, right?
- For Banks, yeah, and for Mae.
- [Kelly] So, for your second and third?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Was that, I
mean, was that like a...
Because you had your
first one in the hospital.
- [Hilary] Yeah.
- [Kelly] And you had a
fine experience, probably.
But what was the reason, why'd
you want to do home birth?
Because it kind of, terrifies me,
because I had complications.
So, you never know when you're
going to have complications.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, you know what?
I think that I had a
really easy first birth,
with Luca in the hospital.
So I was kind of like, "All right,
I know my body can do this".
I didn't have any issues.
- Great body, okay yeah.
(audience and Hilary laugh)
My body was not that body.
- You know what? Some people like aren't,
birthers like that, I don't know.
- Yeah, my sister's like you.
- My mom was like you.
So, it's weird.
I was very like, much
more comfortable doing it
in the hospital for the first time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then I watched Ricky Lake's
"The Business of Being
Born" and I was like,
"I think I could do this,
I think I can do it".
- Wait, I missed that.
So wait, it was just like
a home birthing video?
- It's a home birth documentary.
- Oh, I missed that.
- You know what was really cool
about the home birth, Kelly?
Is like, you know, you're
bringing a baby into the world.
That's some of the hardest
work that anybody can do.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- And they don't let you have
like, water in the hospital
or food or snacks.
And you're about to like,
work the hardest you've ever worked.
To like, push a baby out.
- So, at home you get all...
- Oh, I had sugar fish in bed,
I had a glass of rose afterwards.
- You had sushi?
- I had sushi in my bed with
my baby and a glass of rose
that I actually was like,
clawing at the bed to have.
And I took a sip
afterwards and I was like,
"Eh, this is not doing it for me".
(audience laughs)
But the day after I had some.
- That's amazing, I'm so glad.
That's such a cool experience too,
for like, your kids when they grow up.
It's like, you are born at
home, that's so special.
- You know what?
It's kind of, the most
hippy-dippy thing about me.
Like to have like, my kids
around while I'm birthing,
Like, at first I thought
it was really weird,
but it was really beautiful
to like, bring another family
member in with everyone else.
- I don't think it's very hippy-dippy,
I think it's self-sustaining.
It's like, you can do
everything at your home.
I think that's awesome.
- You know what?
One of my favorite memories was like,
Luca decided to sing Mae happy birthday.
And I was like, I've never heard of anyone
singing happy birthday on a
first birth, like entering date.
But he was like, "We should
sing her happy birthday".
And I was like, "Yeah, right".
- I think that's so precious.
I, here's the thing.
- He's my sweet child.
- I love, is that your oldest?
- Yes.
- Okay, okay, okay.
(Hilary chuckles)
Okay, so after three kids,
are your friends coming to
you for a lot of advice?
Because I've actually had a
couple people on this couch,
say that they come to you for advice.
Like you're like, a super mom.
Like Mandy's one of them,
Mandy Moore was just here.
- Mandy's the best,
she's also a super mom.
So, you know what, I think,
just because I've been
doing this for 10 years
and a lot of my friends
just had babies, this year.
So, I was obviously so excited for them.
And then, you don't want to like,
take anyone's experience away, you know?
Like, everyone goes
through it differently.
- Yeah, it's different.
- I never wanted to be
like, mommy know it all,
but of course I love talking about kids.
And so, I think the biggest
advice I would always give,
would just be like, don't get
fooled by the first two weeks,
because you have like, an angel baby
and they're just, they haven't woken yet.
- Uh-huh.
- [Hilary] You have those
friends that are like,
"This baby is sleeping through the night.
Oh, my God, it's already".
(audience laughs)
And I'm like, "they don't
know that they've entered
the world yet".
- [Kelly] Or perhaps, the first year.
You're like, "God, they're the kindest".
They eat everything, they do everything,
they're so nice.
And then, it's just like...
(Kelly groans)
You're like, you're like,
"What is happening?"
- Oh yeah, my friend will be like,
"My daughter's eating
curry and green things".
And you're like...
- [Kelly] Enjoy it.
(Kelly laughs)
- Wait, just wait.
Soon, it's going to be
like wiped off the...
- [Kelly] I hate this.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's so weird.
(audience applauds)
Her new show is called
"How I Met Your Father".
You can see it on Hulu
and it's just been renewed
for a second season.
Congratulations.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much.
- That's so awesome.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] So, you play Sophie,
who's explaining how she
met her son's father, right?
- Yeah, so it, you know,
it's a kind of like,
an extension of the "How
I Met Your Mother" show.
Because we're just, you
know, we're borrowing
how to tell that story
to your, your child.
And in this case, Kim Catrall
plays the future Sophie,
which is so amazing.
- That's awesome.
- I know, I love her
so much and she's just,
watching her, I'm like,
"Sophie, made good choices,
she ended up okay".
Because like, this whole
adventure of the show
I think we're going to make her,
watch her not make perfect choices.
And you know, she's
just like a young girl,
living in New York, who's 30
and trying to find herself
and find her footing and find true love.
And she's like, really
holding onto the fact
that true love exists
and is out there for her.
- Yeah.
- You know, in the times of like,
everything being so
accessible and being swipeable
and endless options, it's a
really fun show to incorporate
like, what we're dealing with
in modern world right now.
How fast everything is moving.
- I know, I know, it's great.
Well, speaking of meeting fathers,
so I've worked with your husband too.
- I know.
- So I, we were talking
about this backstage,
but I actually didn't know
that he was your husband.
I just missed that.
And I was like, "Wait, what?"
And he wrote one of my favorite
songs called, "Someone".
It's on one of my albums and it's,
I've actually covered it on
here, as a Kelly classic.
- I think you did, not too long ago.
- [Kelly] I know, I love it.
It's literally one of my favorite songs.
It's one of those songs
that people ask me,
if you could've written
any of your songs, like,
because I write a lot of mine,
but some of them I don't
and that's one of them that I'm like.
- You wish you had written.
- [Kelly] I wish I'd written.
It's just so well done and it's fresh.
And I think it's amazing because
you're an artist as well.
You're a singer, songwriter as well.
And I think that that's really cool,
that y'all, that worked.
Like, sometimes the
artists marrying each other
doesn't work, I think that's so cool.
(audience applauds)
- He's never of complimented
one of my songs,
like he has your vocal on
your song, I'll just say that.
- Okay.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm going to start fights now.
No, but I just think that's awesome.
Like, you're so artistic.
Are your kids showing
signs of being so artistic?
Because you do like everything.
- Yeah, oh thank you.
Well, I try to do, I do some
things better than others,
but thank you.
And it's, you know, we definitely
have a creative household.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And Banks, I would say, my middle child,
is showing the most,
she's just a performer.
Like, she is always performing
and it's really sweet,
but her style's real interesting.
- Oh, that's going to
make the more fun kid.
I like that, okay yeah.
- Usually she's nude, I'm like...
- [Kelly] Did you just say nude?
- Nude.
- That was me.
- Oh, well.
- My Mom could not keep clothes on me.
- If she could turn into you,
I'm just going to let her keep going nude.
- Well, you might want to start
her in therapy now, Hilary.
(audience and Hilary laugh)
I'm just kidding, everyone needs therapy.
- I agree, I agree.
(audience laughs)
- No, but I, I just,
I didn't like clothes.
I was like an exhibitionist
at a very young age.
My mom would be so embarrassed,
I'd just take my clothes off.
- Yeah, that...
- Anywhere.
- That is what she does too.
I just, and you know what?
We do the thing in our house,
we love to pants everybody.
If you're walking by it's
fair game to just, you know.
(Kelly laughs)
If someones got a pair of sweatpants on.
And so, Banks feels like
that's really normal.
And I'm like, "Okay, we should stop some
of these antics because it's not normal".
- So wait, my son loves, my
son loves to moon me right now.
He just thinks it's so funny.
- Because, you know what a pressed ham is?
- He's five.
No, but he is five and he walks in
and he'll pull his
pants down, just perfect
to where you just see a little cheek,
like cheeks just like...
- And you'll be like, on
a zoom call or something.
- And he'll turn around
and he'll be like "What?"
(Hilary and audience laugh)
And I'm like, it's kind of shows a little,
like a lot of personality.
(Hilary laughs)
So, I should probably
tell him not to do it.
- A pressed ham is when you do that,
but you go put it on like a glass door.
- Oh yeah, you press it?
Oh, okay, I didn't know that was the name.
- [Hilary] Yeah.
My sister and I used to do it,
when we would drive from Texas to LA
and my mom would have no do no idea.
We would do it in the
back seat of the car.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
Those car rides are long,
two days, you've got to
like entertain yourself.
- [Kelly] You've got...
And entertain the world.
- I'm going to teach your kid
bad things if we ever meet.
- Yeah, apparently I allow
them to do them anyway.
So, we're we're nailing motherhood.
No, but who wins?
I want to ask, who wins in like,
a real life argument at your house?
Does one of you kind of
back off or are you good?
- So, he's a little too quick,
he's a writer, obviously.
You wanted to write that
song, he's a damn good writer.
So, he works with words all day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then when we fight
and I've been like,
dealing with children brains, I'm like...
(Hilary mumbles)
I can't like form the sentence
and he's like lashing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we don't really fight a lot,
but when we do it can get
pretty heated, you know?
- Yeah.
- And so, he will have all
these phenomenal words to say
and just like, go in.
And I'll just be like
stunned for a second.
And if, and then I'll like hide his keys,
because it'll make me feel...
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- Oh, my God.
- Wow, she's a little crazy.
- I actually love you.
(audience applauds)
- One time, one time his phone was like,
sitting on the couch
and I was just like...
(Hilary groans)
And he like, wow, stormed out of the room.
And I just slipped it in the couch.
(audience and Kelly applaud)
- Oh my God, I love you.
I'm going to start, I might
start doing that on my kids,
just to mess with them
when they're disrespectful.
(Kelly and Hilary laugh)
It was so lovely to see you.
- [Hilary] Oh my gosh.
- I love hanging with
you, you're such a...
(audience applauds)
- I love hanging with
you, I love your show.
- A great guest.
- I have to tell you,
when Fran, I call her
Fran, Fran from the show.
Francia, when she came
on I was so jealous.
I was like, "I haven't even been on".
- [Kelly] Wait, we've
been talking about this.
- How'd you get on?
- Wait, I'm so glad you
brought it up though,
because she brought me
hot sauce and she made it.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's amazing.
- I know.
- [Kelly] Have you had it?
- Yeah and when she comes over to my house
and she doesn't bring it,
I'm like, "Why did you come?"
- [Kelly] Rude.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Don't you know the arrangement here?
- You can't show people that, yeah.
- I know and we want to sell it so bad.
I want to call it...
- You should sell it.
- Francia's Salsia.
- No, I'm telling you she should sell it.
I've literally been
talking about that salsa
since she left.
- I know, but she's really
being like, very difficult
about trying to just
supplement fresh cilantro
for like, dried cilantro.
I'm like, just try it so we
can see if we can bottle the...
(beeping)
(Kelly laughs)
- Sorry...
(beeping)
(Kelly laughs)
- No, but it is, it's an amazing salsa.
Y'all should do that,
that's a very smart idea.
All right, everybody new episodes of
"How I Met Your Father"
drop every Tuesday, on Hulu.